foreign foreign
[Music]
he mentions in his book my dear brothers
and we did not Grant to any man before
you eternity so if you die would you
then be Eternal Every Soul shall taste
death and we will test you with evil and
with good as a test
and to us will be your return Allah
shows us clearly my dear brothers that
no human is granted immortality that no
one shall live forever that every single
one of us will come to one will come to
a day where we have to pass away a day
that we will have to stand in front of
Allah
and that this world is nothing but a
diversion and an amusement and indeed
the home of the Hereafter is the eternal
life if only they knew my dear brothers
alhamdulillah Allah has blessed us with
Islam and Allah has blessed us with Iman
but my dear brothers you have to
implement and utilize these verses that
we are mentioning Allah tells us that no
human is granted immortality that you
will pass away and Allah tells us is the
life of Eternity and that this world is
a life that is temporary not only does
Allah tell us this but Allah
shows you clearly loved ones or friends
or families or people passing away
so it is no doubt to you that you will
also come to pass Allah says
that every single soul shall take step
so if Allah blessed you with Iman and
Islam and believing in the Quran then
Implement these verses and work for your
because
afterlife is the one that will be
Eternal this life my dear brothers as
you have seen yourselves is temporary
don't don't guarantee for yourself that
you're going to live tomorrow don't
guarantee for yourself that oh I'll stop
praying next week or I'll stop fasting
next Ramadan don't guarantee yourself
these things my dear brothers likewise
many of us are aware that Ramadan is
only a few weeks away about three weeks
away
and many people alhamdulillah they start
to prepare for Ramadan they start to do
extra good deeds in the month of to get
themselves used to and increase
themselves in getting used to
remembering Allah so that in Ramadan
they can increase even more but
unfortunately there are some people who
only worship Ramadan or it is as if they
worship Ramadan maybe they're not
praying the whole year maybe they're
drinking alcohol the whole year but what
Ramadan comes I'm going to start fasting
last check for them to start fasting is
something but don't stop fasting and are
not praying or start fasting and in the
evening wasting time or doing Haram
or while they're fasting backbiting
people Allah is not in need of these
kind of people's fast
if it is that you're only refraining
from food and drink and that you're
indulging in all the other sins then
Allah is in no need of you to leave off
your drink and your and your food my
dear brothers the habits that you want
alhamdulillah many of you I'm sure I
think good thoughts of my brothers and
that they are good people that
Insha'Allah they will only increase upon
whatever they're doing now in Ramadan
but my dear brothers whatever you want
to continue after Ramadan whatever good
habits you want to continue during
Ramadan and after Ramadan then start it
now don't wait for Ramadan why because
the Lord of Ramadan is the Lord of all
the other months
it's increase in Remembering Allah in
these days my dear brothers lest oh it
may be the Allah
blesses you with the ability of
continuing after Ramadan these Good
Deeds reading the Quran fast and
voluntary uh fast praying voluntary
prayers and maybe Allah gives you the
topic to continue my dear brothers so
take it seriously take this preparation
and shall seriously my dear brothers
likewise for all those who may be
indulgent in sins then I will recommend
for them to use Ramadan as a stepping
stone to all the other years
and for the rest of their life use
Ramadan as a stepping stone in you
leaving away the Haram that you may have
been doing for many years
that whoever first Ramadan with Iman
and hoping in Allah
hoping that Allah's reward then he has
all of his previous sins forgiven so no
doubt that this is an opportunity that
we must take my dear brothers and use
this as a stepping stone for you to
continue the rest of your life and
inshallah when that day comes where you
have to meet Allah the day comes that
you that has been appointed over you for
my local Mo to come and take your soul
that Allah takes your soul in a way that
is pleasing to you in a way that is
pleasing to those who loved you so those
those who loved you from your parents
and your brothers will be like
subhanallah insha Allah I have a good
ending like he had a good ending because
many people my dear brothers who keep
saying to themselves tomorrow tomorrow
they end up dying in that sin and like
this person is under the threat of
entering the Hellfire
no soul knows
which land he will die in
how many of us spend our days seeking
the Dunya and even go even going to the
extent of compromising our in order to
get the Dunya how can we be so heedless
my dear brothers when death is on our
doorstep and we are unaware of when and
where how and how we will die some
people die worshiping Allah
or immediately after doing some sort of
worship whether it be prayer or helping
someone for the sake of Allah and many
die who may have not prayed for it for
for five to ten years and they died in
that state
or even worse they died in a state of
committing Haram
Allah mentions foreign
to take your soul when that time comes
my dear brothers it will not be delayed
by an hour nor will it be brought forth
foreign
who narrated that the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he mentioned
increase increase in remembering the
destroyer of desires what is it that the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is referring to my dear
brothers what is it that he's telling us
to increase in the thing that destroys
your desires the thing that will destroy
your desires is remembering most of my
dear brothers remembering death why
because when you when you're about to
commit that Haram when you're about to
miss that prayer
when you're about to drink that illegal
intoxicant you remember that you're
going to pass away you remember that it
may be in an hour or in half an hour my
time to meet Allah
and when you remember that death what
does it do it destroys your desires
that's why the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said increase in the
remembrance of the destroyer of desires
because my dear brothers You're not
blame worthy it's not a blameworthy
thing for you to have desires for you to
feel and to be enticed into doing Haram
Allah
that the soul it orders itself to do
evil that the soul it inclines to doing
evil
but you're rewarded for restraining your
soul you're rewarded for fighting back
and as for the one who fears the day
that he will have to stand in front of
his Lord
and he restricted his soul from
following its desires you wanted to go
and do the Haram but you remembered
Allah you remembered Allah
and you restrained your soul you
restricted your soul from following its
desires foreign
my dear brothers so the next time you
want to do some Haram restrain and
restrict your soul from doing it for
indeed you will be rewarded for it
Every Soul shall taste death and you
will be paid your wages in full on the
day of Resurrection
Will Not Waste Your Deeds my dear
brothers
foreign
you will be paid full on the day of
Resurrection for that which you did so
he who has become distant or who has
been the one who has been allowed to be
distanced from the fire and entered into
Paradise will be successful and the life
of this world is only enjoyment and
delusion
alhamdulillah
my dear brothers it was narrated by
Usman may Allah be pleased with him
so he was delivering a sermon and he
mentioned oh listen carefully my dear
brothers o son of Adam know that the
angel of death who has been assigned to
you has not ceased to pass by you and
move on to others ever since you have
been in this world but it is as if he is
about to pass by someone else and move
on to Target you
so be careful and prepare for him by
correcting your deeds and do not forget
him for he for indeed he does not forget
you
I know o son of Adam if you are heedless
about yourself and do not prepare no one
else will prepare for you you must meet
Allah the mighty and Majestic so take
care so take for yourself and do not
leave it for someone else may peace be
upon you notice Here My Dear Brothers
this advice that um
is giving to the Believers in on the
member is a very heavy piece of advice
and he's mentioning that do not feel
that it is as if the the medical mode
the one who has been appointed to take
your soul don't think that he's not
going to come to you my dear brothers
but rather the way you should think is
that he may be passing by someone else
he's about to complete his job on other
people that that he has been appointed
to take their souls at that time and
you're next on the list don't think for
yourself that oh I still have five years
I still have 10 years or I am young I'm
healthy because I don't have a terminal
illness because I'm only 30 40 years old
and people die 60 70 80 that I don't
need to do nothing my dear brothers
how many people were healthy and died
for no reason
and how many people were sick and lived
a long life how many people were told
that they only have two to three months
left to live or a couple of weeks to
live and they ended up living a life a
long life
a healthy long life and how many people
were healthy young people and died for
no reason my dear brothers I mentioned
this story many times why because it is
a reminder to myself not only to myself
but to my brothers the young brother who
used to attend a Masjid over 10 years
ago he died roughly about 10 years ago
he used to attend a Masjid to the gurus
and he was only 15 or 14 years old and
he would be here every single weekend
for the durus and he would study he
would attend the Masjid whenever he
canceled why because he knows in it is
more reward than praying at home so he
would strive to worship Allah he would
he would he would do Jihad in trying to
worship Allah and and do good deeds
this individual this young boy as he was
coming out of school high school and he
ran across the road and the bus hit him
and he died but my dear brothers how did
he die he never only died because the
bus killed him but he was running across
the road to try to make the bus so he
can go to Salah in the Masjid so he can
make Salah in the Masjid that insha
Allah this is a good ending why because
he was running for the sake of Allah he
was running to make it to the message so
he can worship His Lord and that's how
he passed away
and how many people passed away
intoxicated
we have we have young boys we have young
boys who passed away we know young
people from the community who are part
of gangs
and they died because of their postcode
or they died because they had they had a
fight with an individual
they may have died after being
intoxicated or after committing Haram or
not praying for days on end and last
check this is a scary ending my dear
brothers so take heed and take a lesson
from this my dear brothers the wise
person he learns from other people's
mistakes so work for your before it's
too late